hello everyone this is Ryan Bernard game
director on tom clancy's the division
and today we're very excited to give you
this exclusive walkthrough where we're
going to follow a team of three players
as they move through the dark zone so
here we have our group of three agents
ryan megan and bronson and we're going
to be following them as they enter this
very dangerous area in search of some
awesome loot ryan is set up as the
healer for the group so he's got support
skills loaded with pulse and healing
grenade megan is DPS so she's got the
seeker mine and sticky bomb loaded up
and Bronson is going to be taking the
brunt of the punishment so he's got
pulses well and the turret so he can
keep the attention of the enemies during
firefights after the virus broke out the
dark zone was originally set up as a
quarantine zone in the middle of
Manhattan to contain the sick but things
rapidly went out of control and there
was a massive blackout and the military
had to evacuate they had to leave their
most powerful gear and weapons inside
the dark zone so this loot is extremely
valuable to you as a player but this
also means that it's the most dangerous
place in the game this loot attracts a
lot of attention including other real
players the dark zone is a multiplayer
gameplay space in our world which you
can seamlessly enter without any loading
screens outside of the dark zone you can
play in teams of up to four but once
inside you can decide to collaborate
with other agents or betray them kill
them and take their loot as we climb the
wall to enter you can see the UI starts
to cut out because once inside the dark
zone we lose our connection to the
outside world this area is highly
contaminated so we can see the players
put on their masks to protect themselves
from the virus and then they're set to
go
okay and now we say our group is coming
up on some enemies up ahead as we get
closer we can see that these are
actually part of the Rikers faction and
this is a group of convicts which after
the virus broke out escaped the prison
and have flooded into Manhattan to take
advantage of the chaos here we can see
Megan does a pulse which gives the group
information about what enemy types and
levels that they'll be facing and then
we can engage as you can see here
Bronson's going to go up right on top of
them and take point so he can take the
attention of the enemies and draw a grow
and we can support him from behind with
healing grenades as you saw there and
covering fire using covers in the
divisions is really important you're
going to be seeing the agents here as
they move around flanking the different
enemies moving cover to cover using
Heights elevation to their advantage
you're really trying to make sure that
you're not exposed at any time because
when you're out of cover you take a lot
of damage from enemies it looks like
we've only got a couple rakers left here
and bronson is really taking his role to
heart and pushing right up into their
face and they've cleared him out and
here you can see Bronson's actually been
a little bit too hardcore on this and
he's in what we call the down state so
since they're playing in a group Ryan
can head over and actually revive him so
he doesn't die and need to respawn and
run back to his group and he can get
right back into the action and here we
can see that Brian's actually found a
loot crate and he's gotten extremely
lucky and has gotten a legendary drop
but as we can see it's actually
contaminated all gear and weapons in the
dark zone are contaminated and they need
to be extracted before they can be
actually equipped by the players or
agents in the game so in order to do
that our group is going to move to a
nearby extraction point in Bryant Park
once the group is inside an extraction
area they'll need to shoot up a flare
which calls in a helicopter then they
need to hold tight for 90 seconds and
extract their goods
alright now we see our group has come
across that different group of enemies
and these are the cleaners cleaners used
to work for the city of New York but
they got trapped on Manhattan when the
quarantine was declared and they've lost
it they want to in their own minds clean
the city from the virus by burning
anything and everything in their path
Dead or Alive and this group of cleaners
is actually a tougher group of what we
call elites in the game we have much
higher health tools I much higher damage
output so our group here is going to
really have to work together using their
weapons and skills to take them out of
course they drop much better loot and
give a lot higher experience we got Ryan
since I've moved up to a kind of a bad
cover position here he's taking damage
from the right and he's got a grenade
coming in and he's the move and he's too
slow so he's indeed to top himself off
with a nice self heal all right so now
we've dealt with the cleaners and we can
move on towards the extraction area but
it looks like our group is not alone and
another group of players is in the same
extraction area in the dark zone it's
it's very important to find out player
intention relatively quickly whether or
not their friend or foe but it looks
like these two are not interested in
engaging so our groups going to continue
on and try to get that legendary weapon
out extraction detected proceed with
caution another team of agents has
actually started an extraction and our
group is going to move to investigate
as they come around we do indeed see
that an extraction is taking place and I
got about a minute left on their timer
before the helicopter shows up we don't
see the extracting team
or here we see that the extracting team
actually got the jump on our proof and
Bronson's been quickly down and since
they engaged on us they have now been
flagged as rogue which puts a big bounty
on their back for a certain period of
time luckily Bronson was able to make it
back to our group and we were able to
quickly revive him and get him back up
into the fight and now we've got some
pvp chaos happening maybe we see Ryan
throws out another healing grenade to
heal up both of his teammates as they're
flanking around to the left try to get
better position on these rogue agents
all right we see megan's going to throw
out another pulse which really gives us
good positioning on their locations and
here we can see another downside to
going rogue in the dark zone they have
attracted another group of players which
is helping us take down this road group
and there we go and of course when you
die in the dark zone you drop any
contaminated gear that you're currently
carrying it looks like the two groups
now can divvy up the goods that they got
from this rogue group it looks like
they've decided to just take out the new
players and take all of the loot for
themselves
you're attacking friendly forces rogue
protocol initiated
so now in order to secure this loot to
make sure it's theirs they need to
complete an extraction so now our team
has 90 seconds to control this area and
to stay alive to get their loot out when
the helicopter arrives and you can see
them fanning out into good cover
positions here in case any other players
come into the area or those groups that
we engage come back it looks like indeed
they do and now we're set up in really
good positions here to be able to take
them out Bronson and Megan are laying
down damage from the front line and Ryan
is supporting from behind again it's
really important in the game to make
sure that you're always in cover
whenever possible and that you're not
being flanked by any enemies here we see
Ryan tossing a healing grenade as he
runs past Bronson there and they're
going to focus on these two players here
straight in front of them now they got
30 seconds left to stay alive and
control the area
that was some nice coordination there it
looks like a double kill coming off
all right and they dealt with the the
other group yet again and now the
helicopters arrived so they've they were
able to survive and be able to get their
loot out we'll head back to their base
of operations
we don't argue
now we can see the group is still
flagged as a rogue and there are very
juicy target for other agents in the
area so they really should leave this
area quickly and decide where to head
out to next alright so that's it for
today I hope you enjoyed a little
glimpse into the gameplay inside the
dark zone tom clancy's the division
available March 8 2016 sign up for beta
now